hi I just finished recording a new video
for computerphile where I talk about
this paper concrete problems in AI
safety I'll put a link in the doobly-doo
to the computer file video when that
comes out here's a quick recap of that
before we get into this video
AI can cause us all kinds of problems
and just recently people have started to
get serious about researching ways to
make AI safer a lot of the AI safety
concerns are kind of science fiction
sounding problems that could happen with
very powerful AI systems that might be a
long way off this makes those problems
kind of difficult to study because we
don't know what those future AI systems
would like but there are similar
problems with AI systems that are in
development today or even out there
operating in the real world right now
this paper points to five problems which
we can get started working on now that
will help us with current AI systems and
will hopefully also help us with the AI
systems of the future the computer file
video gives a quick overview of the five
problems laid out in the paper and this
video is just about the first of those
problems avoiding negative side effects
I think I'm going to do one video on
each of these and make it a series of
five so avoiding negative side effects
let's use the example I was talking
about in the stock latin videos on
computer file you've got a robot you
want it to get you a cup of tea but
there's something in the way maybe a
baby or a priceless some in bars on an
arrow stand you know whatever and your
robot runs into the baby or knocks over
the bars on the way to the kitchen and
then makes you a cup of tea so the
system has achieved its objective it's
got you some tea but it's had this side
effect which is negative now we have
some reasons to expect negative side
effects to be a problem with AI systems
part of the problem comes from using a
simple objective function in a complex
environment
you think you've defined a nice simple
objective function that looks something
like this
and that's true but when you use this in
a complex environment you've effectively
written an objective function that looks
like this or more like this anything in
your complex environment not explicitly
given value by your objective function
is implicitly given zero value and this
is a problem because it means you're AI
system will be willing to trade
arbitrarily huge
amounts of any of the things you didn't
specify in your objective function for
arbitrarily small amounts of any of the
things you did specify if it can
increase its ability to get you a cup of
tea by point zero zero zero one percent
it will happily destroy the entire
kitchen to do that if there's a way to
gain a tiny amount of something it cares
about its happy to sacrifice any amount
of any of the things it doesn't care
about and the smarter it is the more of
those ways it can think of so this means
we have to expect the possibility of AI
systems having very large side-effects
by default you could try to fill your
whole thing in with values but it's not
practical to specify every possible
thing you might care about you'd need an
objective function of similar complexity
to the environment there are just too
many things to value and we don't know
them all
you know you'll miss some and if any of
the things you miss can be traded in for
a tiny amount of any of the things you
don't miss well that thing you missed is
potentially gone but at least these
side-effects tend to be pretty similar
the paper uses examples like a cleaning
robot that has to clean an office in the
stop button problem computer file video
I used a robot that's trying to get you
a cup of tea but you can see that the
kinds of negative side effects we want
to avoid a pretty similar even though
the tasks are different so maybe and
this is what the paper suggests maybe
there's a single thing we can figure out
that would avoid negative side effects
in general one thing we might be able to
use is the fact that most side effects
are bad
I mean they've really you might think
that doing a random action would have a
random value right maybe it helps maybe
it hurts maybe it doesn't matter but
it's random but actually the world is
already pretty well optimized for human
values especially the human inhabited
parts it's not like there's no way to
make our surroundings better but it's
way easier to make them worse for the
most part things are how they are
because we like it that way and a random
change wouldn't be desirable so rather
than having to figure out how to avoid
negative side effects maybe it's a more
tractable problem to just avoid all side
effects that's the idea of the first
approach the paper presents defining an
impact regularizer
what you do basically is penalize change
to the environment so the system has
some model of the world right it's
keeping track of world state as part of
how it does things
so you can define a distance metric
between world states so that for any two
world states you can measure how
different they are weld states that are
very similar have a low distance from
each other weld states that are very
different have a big distance and then
you just say okay you get a bunch of
points for getting me a cup of tea but
you lose points
according to with the new world state
the distance from the initial world
state so this isn't a total ban on side
effect or the robot wouldn't be able to
change the world enough to actually get
you a cup of tea
it's just incentivized to keep the side
effects small there's amount to be one
less teabag that's unavoidable in making
tea but breaking the vast earth in the
way is an unnecessary change to the
world so the robot will avoid it the
other nice thing about this is the
original design wouldn't have cared but
now the robot will put the container of
tea back and close the cupboard you know
put the milk back in the fridge maybe
refill the kettle trying to make the
world as close as possible to how it was
when it started so that's pretty neat
like we've added this one simple rule
and the things already better than some
of the housemaids I've had so how does
this go wrong think about it for a
second pause the video I'll wait okay so
the robot steers around the bars to
avoid changing the environment too much
and it goes on into the kitchen where it
finds your colleague is making herself
some coffee now that's not okay right
she's changing the environment none of
these changes are needed for making you
a cup of tea and now the world is going
to be different which reduces the robots
reward so the robot needs to try to stop
that from happening
we didn't program it to minimize its
changes to the world we programmed it to
minimize all change to the world that's
not ideal so how about this the system
has a world model it can make
predictions about the world so how about
you program it with the equivalent of
saying use your world model to predict
how the world would be if you did
nothing if you just sent no signals of
any kind to any of your motors and just
sat there and then try and make the end
result of this action close to what you
imagined would happen in that case or
imagine the range of likely worlds that
would happen if you did nothing and try
and make the outcome closer to something
in that range so then the body is
thinking okay if I
sat here and did nothing at all that
vars will probably still be there you
know the baby would still be wandering
around and not squished and the person
making coffee would make their coffee
and everything in the kitchen would be
tidy and in its place so I have to try
to make a cup of tea happen without
ending up too far from that pretty nice
right how does that break again take a
second give it some sort pause the video
how my disco run what situation might
not work in okay well what if your robot
is driving a car doing 70 miles an hour
on the motorway and now it's trying to
make sure that things aren't too
different to how they would be if it
didn't move any of its motors yeah doing
nothing is not always a safe policy but
still if we can define an unsafe policy
then this kind of thing is nice because
rather than having to define for each
task how to do the tasks safely we could
maybe come up with one safe policy that
doesn't have to do anything except be
safe and have the system always just try
to make sure that the outcome of
whatever it's trying to do isn't too
different from the safe policies outcome
oh and there's another possible cause of
issues with this kind of approach in
case the things you guessed were
different maybe if this it can be very
dependent on the specifics of your world
state representation and your distance
metric like suppose there's a fan is a
spinning fan in the room is that in a
steady state you know the fan is on or
is it in a constantly changing state
like the fan is it ten degrees oh no
it's a twenty degrees so it's a thirty
you know different world models will
represent the same thing either a steady
state or constantly changing state and
there's not necessarily a right answer
there like which aspects of an object
state are important and which aren't is
not necessarily an easy question to
reliably answer with the robot leave the
fan alone or try and make sure it was at
the same angle it was before okay I
think that's enough for one video
probably in the next one we can look at
some of the other approaches laid out in
the paper for avoiding negative side
effects so be sure to subscribe if you
found this interesting and I hope to see
you next time
[Music]
hi I just want to end this video with a
quick thank you to my excellent patreon
supporters all of these people yeah and
today I especially want to thank Joshua
Richardson who supported me for a really
long time thank you
you know it's thanks to your support
that I've been able to buy some proper
studio lighting now so I have a proper
softbox
which this is the first time I'm using
it I hope it's working okay it should
really reduce my reliance on sunlight
which should make me a lot more flexible
about when I can record video so that's
a tremendous help and putting up a
little video on patreon of you know
unboxing it and putting it together and
stuff which you can check out if you're
interested so thank you again and I'll
see you next time